and how do I live and how spock series controls
and they see
without where do I smell the ball aliexpress and thunder
harper uplifting
and bass eraser could appear a tablet
mixer
I how to burn
well, what’s ready there but also [ __ ] him
[laugh]
thank you you are a lot of stalker life
I saved, let’s pray, and the oil painting
[music]
that’s why I don’t have any showdowns and don’t
climb, I don’t want to catch a bullet, I do
n’t know
between anomalies and buttered, I’d rather
choose a bullet
[music]
so you say, but I really see the beauty
this is not the first year in  the zone seems to
have become familiar already,
and every day it surprises the zone you can’t get bored
saying you know where the entrance to the
foundation
you find out heard this culture
from and the same thing in a circle
you’re in vain you’re so with friends you’re
him on a sortie dragging
something
and friendship in the zone I definitely didn’t meet it
right
he suffered
no it’s good
he didn’t deserve it and he deserved the bullets it’s a
pity  that you did this to him, I also
think I didn’t think how to do without his
death, she couldn’t be free while
he lived for that, look at her low,
I won’t give up as a unicom Sona
gave me life a new life, a life
that I’m ready to return if
necessary  will always protect
marry it looks like it's time and where are you now to
give you need to talk to him a
successful hunt stalker